yo what it dude man y'all know who it is
this your boy elf be pootie you can
catch me on the bootleg hell podcast
show
we going up
yo welcome to the bullet cap show man we
got the homie lpb
pooty in the building welcome man what's
up what's up
orlando's finest oh yeah yo orlando i
feel like is a city in florida
um really just all of central florida
you know i feel like for years didn't
get a lot of love
when it came to the whole state we
always would hear about
you know broward and miami and that
whole side but i feel like the last
three or four years central florida's
been on
just on the [ __ ] come up man so so
explain kind of like what it's like
coming out of orlando you know what i'm
saying because
we think of disney world and you know
what i'm saying like
gonna lie it's kind of big you know what
i'm saying like you said it ain't it
ain't nobody really ever came out of
orlando but we had people like
yeah whoops fire like that you know what
i'm saying um
all the young [ __ ] like coming up now
you know what i'm saying like that's in
my era
so it was like i'm one of the top like
three you know what i'm saying
coming out of the city so it's kind of
big and it's like
you know something special to to my city
because ain't nobody ever did that you
know what i'm saying
do you ever [ __ ] with caskey caskey's a
white boy who was out of
orlando he's he signed with cash money
uh i never heard of him
yeah he's dope you should check them out
yeah so who would you consider the top
three guys you said you're one of the
top three so who are the other two guys
uh
i mean you got glock 9 um hot boy and me
and then you got tyler
you know tyler yeah yeah i was going
crazy he was just he was just in here
the other day yeah
i was with him yeah yeah no he's like
he's you know he's obviously hanging
with post malone yeah exactly
he used to be he's crazy he used to be
in a group called swamp posse
back in the day and uh it was him and uh
a few other uh cats that were you know
who skye is scott
he's out of orlando too but yeah no it's
crazy
so uh you you mentioned the top three
guys
you came up with those guys so what's
your what's your relationship like with
hot boy
and glock nine at the moment
[Music]
do their own thing i do um you know what
i'm saying do you feel like because i do
feel like in florida it seems like
there's a lot more
um tension between everybody than a lot
of other
regions i don't know i mean
people you know have problems everywhere
so i don't think it's only florida but
it's a little crazy out there though
it's crazy right yeah
it is what do you think it is about
florida and like what like what is it do
you think that
that kind of makes makes it a little bit
more amplified out there
oh no i probably believe um i can't
really say
because probably like some people
certain people get more active than
others you know
so i don't really know about that
situation i can just tell you about what
i do you know
that ain't um i can't really speak on
the next people like what they got going
on
how old are you i'm 21 21 yeah
so you uh did you graduate high school
nah shout out in 12th grade actually i
was at the door
he was almost there yeah music started
popping and they were like you know what
i'm good or what happened not even that
i was um i was um
i had the um damn i was in 12th grade i
kept
i the reason why i dropped out because i
[ __ ] down i had to um
i just get in trouble a lot and the
police had like they have to come to my
class all the time get me out of school
and [ __ ] like they happen like
like three times and i was like i'm
tired of that [ __ ] so i couldn't do it
so you'd just be in class and the cops
just come embarrass you and just take
you out of class
yeah i mean they'll like say like if i
got a warrant right
and it'll be popped up out of nowhere
they know where to find you you're in
class exactly
you know what i'm saying so i just like
[ __ ] that i ain't going to school no
more i had to stop
did you get your gd or did you just kind
of keep it moving after that i was on
the road to it
i stopped that [ __ ] too because that's
when music came
in like time i was doing that because i
was in jail and when i got out
i had met with um the management team
i'm with now you know
and then it was like man we gonna take
it to the next level and i started doing
it and that was that
um i saw that you said that you had uh
started like you
you first started rapping you were like
10. yeah i've been rapping probably
younger than that but i mean like you
know what i'm saying like
really getting into the studio was like
15 16 my first time recording
i used to freestyle all the time like at
the lunch tables and [ __ ]
when you were like in high school did
you ever have like a record that kind of
like went viral at school like
that uh yeah yeah um my
first song that i like shot a video to
was um on the block
it was a feature freestyle i made it to
a song though and that [ __ ] went viral
and that [ __ ] was crazy yeah that was
like my first like song that i ever
recorded and
that [ __ ] went crazy like i think i got
like 400 000
oh [ __ ] first song you ever recorded or
the first video you ever recorded like
the first
i want to say the first i i think it was
the first song nah i actually did
something with d-boy but it was like
some [ __ ] that he made up for me you
know what i'm saying i was like nah
he recorded me in the studio but ever
since that i think
on the block was like my first one that
i actually put out put on youtube and
everything you know
i see you got the sniper gang on your
jacket um i i was a i was living in
florida
when kodak was performing at club sky in
tampa
like 200 people before like i was like
there when i saw his whole entire [ __ ]
glow up and like i i always should try
to explain to people like
who aren't from florida like how big he
was at that time
just there yeah like it was like
something special it was like
i never really have seen anything like
it to be honest like i never have seen
anything like
kodak's come up before everyone else
before drake started like you know what
i'm saying but like
it was like crazy how influential
uh what's kodak to what you're doing and
like do you remember like
when he was like bubbling because i
always try to explain it to people but i
think you kind of had to be there
yeah yeah i mean you know what i'm
saying like my cousin hadn't brought
like brought me to his attention like he
was like man
from down south but i was younger than
quite like a year or two younger than
him but
it was like man like around y'all aged
me
you know what i'm saying so when they
showed me him i think the first song i
heard about him was um
i want to say not it wasn't no flocking
i think it was um
yeah hungry hungry like that was my
first sunday
i had a homeboy that's from down that
way you know what i'm saying that i grew
up with like
he had to move from lauderdale and he
was he had not like he was telling us
about i think it was like my ninth grade
yo
i wanna see y'all like my ninth grade
yeah i found out about him
and i was like yo that boy snapping you
know i'm saying i actually ran into him
like a year or two later after that
on my birthday i seen him on my birthday
at the mall he was shopping and [ __ ] i
hadn't
you know chopped it up with him and [ __ ]
you know was it you know what i'm saying
like me seeing him do that [ __ ]
it was it was amazing i'm like damn he
he opened the door for the young dudes
you know
he really did man i think i was like 15
at the time 16 at the time
when i seen dude during that [ __ ] so
yeah i feel like a lot of the florida
waves that's happening now is like
a direct result as to what he kind of
like the foundation yeah
you got to give credit you know what i'm
saying kodak made away he did that
100 um there's this the double xl
freshman cover that's going on right now
there's a voting and all that [ __ ] like
like uh do you feel like you deserve a
slot on that cover oh yeah
definitely especially since like you
know what i'm saying
like i barely did like i don't know like
last year i was i was
i wasn't chill like i was chilling you
know what i'm saying because i was still
dealing with the police and stuff
right so like like i got two big records
that like was
like you know what i'm saying that's
going crazy right now i still got one
batman
like you know oh yeah no by the way you
you you i you got me like a custom
batman
you know versions you're looking out on
that you know what i mean i appreciate
it now yeah the batman joints going
crazy how did you link up with 42 doug
uh i was i was recording in miami i want
to say back in 2019
i was at circle house recording um shout
out to circle house
love that place yeah that's like one of
my favorite studios you won't even know
it's a studio it's just
it's like a mansion yeah what it is
though like you know what i'm saying
they got different rooms yeah yeah yeah
but yeah so boom i had no um i was
recording down that circle
and i hadn't just signed my deal with uh
interscope and
chameleon record you know i'm saying
they brought him and it was like um
i was in a recording he was like man i
got this this this um young cat from um
detroit he's here with gotti cause i've
been new gotti yeah of course
i'm saying but before i sign my deal so
he was telling me got it i'm about to
pull up
he was like he got his artist with him i
want you to [ __ ] with him i'm like all
right i'll check him out you know what
i'm saying i never heard of a
42 dog around this time so when he
walked in i'm looking at him like damn
he looked he's shorter than me so i'm
like yeah i'm just the last kid
and you're you're pretty short right
yeah yeah hang on i ain't even smaller
than me
yeah i think he's smarter than everybody
respectfully
yeah you know i [ __ ] with him though i
saw the video of james harden bending
down to talk to about the sidelines the
other day i was like damn
so i'm like damn i looked at him like
damn all right i'm gonna [ __ ] with him
so they pulled me out in the hallway he
was like
[ __ ] spit you know what i'm saying so
i don't want you to show up
yeah oh yeah definitely i know i am i
sorry so i went and picked the beat you
know what i'm saying i picked the beat i
think with the first beat i went to my
thousand pull up
it was like a like some like turn type
[ __ ] so
like i put it up he went to bobbin head
to us i said you [ __ ] with it like yeah
that [ __ ] walked in the studio
just went to spain yeah i'm freestyling
i think we did a song in like 45 seconds
what 45 minutes i'm tripping
oh it's like 45 seconds the song is like
no it's longer than that
bro went in there no bruh hat went in
there and went crazy to hang a lot he he
went and dropped his look like i think
he did an eight
at first or like he i did his first
eight and i'm looking
and all this in the studio shot like oh
[ __ ] you know what's i say
[ __ ] rap and my daughter was like i was
telling you this [ __ ] who made uh dog
food
right no yeah that's him now so i
wouldn't do my thing that's how that
came about hey i know you're watching
the interview right now thank you for
watching we gotta interrupt this for a
special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssocksofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at niko
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving is they got the
naruto
and i'm not even into that [ __ ] but the
socks are fly and the street fighter
socks crazy licenses odd socks
official.com
keyword bootleg kev right now save 20
off at checkout
yo who uh who's cause you know we've
been seeing like a lot of artists drop
like collab projects like future and uzi
dropped some [ __ ] last year like
who's somebody if you could pick some
anyone to do a whole album with who
would it be
uh i say 42 4 42. you know what i'm
saying we're gonna talk about some [ __ ]
like this
possibly you know what i'm saying it
might be something
what have you noticed um because you
know obviously when you when you start
[ __ ] with a major like an
interscope you know what i'm saying like
things
things switch up from when you're
independent what is the biggest
difference you've noticed
from the independent grind to the major
[ __ ]
with a label you know what i'm saying
they can really make [ __ ] happen like
they could pull a few more screens that
i couldn't pull when i'm
you know what i'm saying so that's why i
can you know say get them credit on that
because they can always like open up
multiple doors instead of just
like it's kind of harder going to
independent route but you know what i'm
saying
it ain't nothing wrong with having help
everybody need help you know what i'm
saying so that's what i
i like i shout out to label too you know
what i'm saying because they
they're good at you know what i'm saying
making [ __ ] happen for you i'm curious
because orlando the area just
florida in general but you know there's
been a lot of legendary football players
that come out of the orlando area
chris johnson you know um but there's no
football team there
on the nfl side yeah so like do you guys
just automatically [ __ ] with the bucks
or the dolphins or the jaguars or is it
like i mean
or is it ucf like do you guys only you
know what i'm saying because shout out
to ucf's there at the college
i was a big football fan when i was
young i used to play sports but i ain't
i'm not really into football now but i
[ __ ] with um my favorite team always
been like green b
oh the the backers oh hackers but i [ __ ]
with like
teams like i [ __ ] with the bucks though
i ain't gonna lie i [ __ ] with the boss
but
i mean they just want a super bowl it's
easy to [ __ ] with them now you know i
mean they were trash for a while
when i lived there they were [ __ ]
horrible
yeah but my favorite quarterback is um
peyton manning all the time oh yeah
peyton manning is a goat
definitely yeah yeah no if he would i
think if he would have played with like
with bill uh well bill belichick he'd
have probably had as many rings as brady
i had did a documentary on him back in
middle school you did a documentary on
peyton manning yeah i had to do some
[ __ ] like i had to draw i drew a picture
like a
painting of him also like wow i was good
at art and [ __ ] like that too so i did
all kind of [ __ ] back in
back in middle school so in school it
was like an assignment yeah and so you
you picked peyton manning as the subject
you really [ __ ] with peyton yeah yeah i
got pictures and [ __ ] of dreams and [ __ ]
have you met him yet no i never met him
would you be like
i mean listen i always tell people i
don't give a [ __ ] to meet many people in
music
but there's certain people like some
actors some athletes that i'd be like
super excited to meet with that is that
somebody for you that you'd be like
geeks
probably back then at the time you know
what i'm saying but i don't really
you know what i'm saying i kind of it
kind of slipped my mind about peyton
manning but
back then i probably would have hang on
was this colts manning or broncos
manning colts
i think they won the championship around
the time when i was against the bears
yes when i was doing um
that same year i think i had a what put
me on them
my teacher she was doing like a raffle
and she was like whatever like you put
like whatever team you pull out of the
jar that's the team you got to stick
with for the
for the year documentary on them and we
ended up winning the championship that
so you pulled the coats i swear to god
and that's what made me start [ __ ]
with him i'm like damn that's crazy
yeah uh the batman record is going crazy
what is like
i'm sure you got a uh an album that
you're getting ready like
what's next um i gotta we probably
mix tape a remix to batman
it's real big ain't no okay what state
is the person from where is he from
matter of fact there's two features okay
give me give me this give me some states
uh i really don't even know what listen
if you say if you say north carolina we
know it's the baby
okay so it's not so but if you say
georgia it could be like
a thousand different rappers i can't
really i don't know i mean i want to say
i don't know i'm gonna say one off from
memphis i think
okay cool so uh yo gotti uh money bag yo
or young dolph's on the remix
uh i'm gonna go with money bag yo i'm
gonna bet let's hey look
let's do it here my money is on money
bag yo
that's who you i mean that'd be fire
maybe key glock
emily choppa maybe but i think i think
it's money bag yo
yeah i think based on his response it's
money back yo shout out money bag yo man
yo you know that man used to own like an
entire like he had like a grown ass
tiger that lived in his backyard yeah
this will have like wild animals for
like
a while that's crazy yeah he's like i
had to get rid of the tiger because my
neighbors was
was complaining because this
[ __ ] had a tiger
that's crazy what is the dumbest thing
you've bought so far or like the
craziest [ __ ] you've bought since you've
gotten some
some money in your pocket obviously not
a tiger
i don't know i don't spend money on like
crazy ass meals you know what i'm saying
meals yeah that's the way i am i [ __ ]
off all my money on food man
i don't think like anything that i buy
like hey when you go to the restaurant
and it's like a new restaurant you're in
a different city do you just order hella
[ __ ] to try everything sometimes i do
that like
i'll do it like my dogs are black bro
you order this i'm ordered that yeah
so i'll be doing my wife i'll just be
like she'll be like you ordered six
things i'm like i know but i
we don't live here i want to try this
[ __ ] like you know what i mean like yeah
like that yeah and then the bill comes
in like [ __ ]
yeah yeah and a lot that should be crazy
yeah
um so the remix to batman's coming
with two artists probably one of them's
money back yeah
what's after that though like do you
have a body of work prepared like yeah
um after three minutes
i'm trying to push out a tape probably
you know what i'm saying just a bit of
the anticipation and [ __ ] for you know
what i'm saying like get it to the point
where they're gonna be like oh yeah
this [ __ ] did his thing like you know
what i'm saying i didn't really drop
nothing last year yeah i dropped nothing
but two
well i'll drop one song actually that
was the record with 42.
address it came out 2019 on my birthday
i released that song and it just took
off last year in april
people think that's probably newer right
a couple years old
about a year now did the pandemic kind
of like
like [ __ ] up the rollout a little bit
and kind of
make like because obviously for
everybody we all had to adjust and like
figure out how to move
except for y'all in florida because
gonna like y'all why the [ __ ] open
i can't really say that because uh you
know i'm saying i was on probation
that's really why two though you know so
i kept getting in trouble i got in
trouble i was in jail
you know that probation sucks man
yeah i'm off that [ __ ] no i've been on
probation since i was like 15.
it's like you got to get permission to
do anything and it's like they want to
they want you to like
forget to ask so they can put your ass
back in jail and charge you more money
and then
it's some wild [ __ ] man and let me ask
you this and somebody who lives in
florida especially the
regional florida you live in we always
see the craziest headlines
come out of florida it's always like
some lady crashed her honda civic into a
taco bell
drive through and stole a baby there's
people spoken
florida got the craziest headlines
anytime you see some wild [ __ ] on the
internet it's always in florida
yeah and it's usually like central
florida like usually it's like st
pete or like it's some like what is it
about florida where [ __ ] are
just a little off
oh no man you know so we got our own way
of doing things
and the white trash in florida is like
really white trash
i'll be trying to tell people like when
i lived in tampa man
the white [ __ ] out there that
are trashy are like dog
they're like like half redneck half like
gator wrangler
half like they're out there smoking meth
and [ __ ] like
yeah now like i just feel like something
there's something about the like florida
in general where [ __ ] like [ __ ] the
wildest [ __ ] happens there bro like
a little wild man yeah yeah that [ __ ]
everywhere
um did you ever [ __ ] with wrestling
coming up because orlando is uh you know
that's where nxt is at that's where all
the wrestlers live there you know what
i'm saying like
i did i used to [ __ ] with john cena
of course i mean of course yeah yeah
triple h yeah all them fools live around
there they either live in tampa
around orlando time i used to party uh
you ever been to tier
yeah i think i did i performed there
before
yeah i used to party with some of the
wrestlers in orlando
shout out to orlando orlando's club
scene is kind of crazy because it's like
a lot of transplants from new york are
there
a lot of puerto ricans are there
downtown orlando
right downtown but it's like it's like a
mix like if you listen to the music it's
like a hybrid of like
new york and just grimy country
[ __ ] like and they meet because there's
a lot of a lot of transplants live there
in orlando
it's crazy is it like kind of annoying
being like from
like like like people having the the uh
stigma of orlando being like this big
tourist destination this big family city
when it's like there's so much more to
it than that
that's a whole lot to orlando orlando
you know because simia is just like the
outskirts orlando
it's west orlando east orlando you know
what i'm saying simi is
like that's orlando but i can't really
say that's like
you know what i'm saying what's orlando
orlando is is
the hoods and [ __ ] because that's what's
out there you know what i'm saying ain't
really like no
disney like disney is 45 minutes away
from where i'm from
mm-hmm no i'm saying so that's like damn
near in between polk county
davenport and all that [ __ ] mm-hmm so
that's like two days like that [ __ ] like
an outskirt kind of
yeah i feel like uh with any because i i
also lived in vegas for a while and it's
like you know vegas has a whole scene
and a whole like
there's like real hoods in vegas but
when we think of vegas we think it's
just the streets
yeah we think of orlando we think of
disney mickey mouse
you know what i'm saying yeah right and
dwight howard
yeah obviously he's not there anymore
but you know yeah
when you were a kid was that like like
dwight was that [ __ ] though you
know what i'm saying they went to the
finals man
i had to [ __ ] with dwight my dad a big
um
the white fan you know i met him too
also i met him before i had no i think
we seen him at um
because i used to go to this boys and
girls club in my community
you know what i'm saying they had like
they had them come to the um
to the boys and girls club he was in the
gym like teaching us you know i'm saying
basketball techniques and [ __ ] like that
well listen you got uh
the remix coming soon to batman yeah um
with money back yo
and another artist yeah um
and then hopefully uh you say you will
get a tape tape coming
so go [ __ ] with that man and i
appreciate you for pulling yo
why okay break down the initials in
front of your name because i saw what it
meant in
on your instagram bio yeah light pole
baby
so what's the light pole baby uh where'd
you get that that from
um all right okay
you know how like you have to okay i was
young as [ __ ] so i used to have to be in
the house
at a certain type of time like my
parents would tell me beat the street
lights home or i'll get in trouble like
i'll be on punishment
right but when they told me i'd be on
punishment i never get put on punishment
you know saying so it was like they were
just trying to
scare me but that [ __ ] ain't falling
through so i still like bucks some
sometimes but when i was younger like
like i want to say like between like
nine to up to like 12.
i thought i used to um i used to have to
be in the house before like
the street lights came on but not really
in the house i just got to be in front
of the house
with my grandma live there's a light
pole that's in front of it like it's
like directly in front of house like
next to our like
um our mailbox right then like the next
house over there's a light pole down you
know what i'm saying so i just stayed so
that was your area
you know what i'm saying so i used to
post up in front of the light pole
after hours you know what i'm saying all
the kids that that was like a little
older they used to be still running out
you know
come and chill with me by the light
poker they knew i couldn't go past that
was yours that was your area light bulb
baby
ah that's fire yeah yeah i like that man
well look
appreciate you for pulling up definitely
go uh [ __ ] tap in we're going
we're gonna be doing a freestyle too so
if you watch this go watch the freestyle
as well man
yeah boom boo lay cap show